la pharmacie de tinhan gun est prête
depuis des semaines à vacciner des
clients contre la coved 19 pharmacienne
vaccine actrice va les accueillir et le
téléphone ne dérougit pas à chaque jour
mes patients le demandent les personnes
âgées ont vraiment hâte qu'on puisse
leur donner
depuis janvier le sous sol sera
réaménagé en salles d'attentes pour
augmenter la capacité de vaccination
pour elle il est grand temps de recourir
aux services des pharmaciens dans la
campagne de vaccination
on a une capacité par semaine on estime
200 milles à 125000 vaccin que le
gouvernement vise une couverture
vaccinale de 70% alors avec l'apport des
pharmacies ça va pouvoir atteindre à ce
niveau là nous on est disponible et en
attend juste les vaccins pour me vire
chichaoua r il est grand temps d'agir
si vous savez combien d'appels qu'on a
par chose je suis contente que les
pharmaciens prennent la place
actuellement et pis que les gens voient
qu'on prend nos classes on est beaucoup
de pharmacies partout au québec donc on
peut rejoindre la population beaucoup
plus facilement que n'importe qui selon
un sondage de l'association des
pharmaciens du canada
43 % des canadiens ont choisi les
pharmacies comme l'endroit privilégié
pour recevoir leur vaccin contre la
copie de 19,6 possible de faire à la
pharmacie moi j ai réussi mais je pense
qu'il va peut-être y avoir moins
d'achalandage
je me sentirais plus sécure de venir ici
n'importe où sauf et je pense qu'il faut
que ça arrive et les pharmacies sont
bien passées
la pharmacie de benoît morin est aussi
prête les vaccins coved vont être
entreposées ici faute d' espaces la
vaccination se déroulera dans le
sous-sol de l'église en face de sa
pharmacie
on a eu une bonne pratique avec
l'influenza c'est à dire qu on a vacciné
pendant trois mois ce qu'on veut faire
c'est aller chercher la clientèle
vulnérable au départ qui a pas été
vaccinés dans les grands ensembles
l'alberta a annoncé cette semaine que
les pharmacies commenceront la
vaccination dès le début du mois de mars
pour la saskatchewan l'ontario et le
québec on parle du mois d'avril
encore faudra-t-il recevoir les doses de
vaccin promis par les compagnies
pharmaceutiques ici marie michel lauzon
radio canada
real